a few weeks after the devastating
earthquake in Haiti Kristalina Georgieva
European Commissioner for international
cooperation humanitarian aid and crisis
response visited some Commission funded
humanitarian relief projects the
international community responded
swiftly to this crisis do you in
particular they want we have deployed
both resources and people here in greedy
day two we mobilized 25 of our member
countries through the civil protection
coordination mechanism and now what we
see is that the international community
has done quite well to be up to the task
in the emergency the release date now we
have to be up to the task in the
recovery state as well because we are
now at a very critical junction when the
first response to the disaster was
reasonably good and strong now we need
to retain the continuation of this
response with the EU is provided like a
million euros persistence up I should
stress that was the very first decision
the new commission made in the very
first hour of its existence and the
question is helping deployed this 90
million euros in a way that is best
fitting the needs of the Haitian people
the projects funded by the European
Commission are implemented by its
humanitarian partners an example is a
health center in our bone which is run
by the NGO morteza which is providing
health check-ups for local people here
another partner handicap international
worked with people who have lost limbs
prosthetics experts still filled kyojin
explains that it takes time for stunts
to heal and only then can artificial
limbs be fitted the people stuff is not
yet waiting we are we just making
something some evaluation to check this
term
this is the stuff for now just we valued
people see if there's tom is good
because stomp suppose to take one or two
or three months to be good that depends
of the picture the number one priority
with the race now we hear them above our
heads is to ensure shelter for people
and to deal with the Sanitation these
two things are connected the food and
water having getting put on the table
water more or less this is handled well
but getting group that can sustain the
rains we still need to do we have work
to do and get in sanitation getting
sanitation in the in the case of piraeus
committee is very important because it
has health implications as well the one
that touched me most was a girl called
Sheila who wasted me when we were
passing through Jack Mel so we stop with
the car and I open the the window and I
said you know Bonjour and then she
offered me a big piece of orange with a
big smile on her face and these are the
signs of the tremendous quality of the
Haitian people that I will hold in my
heart when I come back to Brussels and
that would keep me going to make sure we
help as much as we can